fonctionnaires sont les boucs émissaires
et c'est toujours le même procédé c'est
à dire vous dire l'état coûte trop cher
les services publics touchés à la
fonction publique ou trop chers
qu'ailleurs avec encore une fois
monsieur migaud qui est venu devant la
commission on a on connaît à l'avance
quasiment le programme du gouvernement
je peux vous dire qu'ils vont
effectivement supprimer son amie
fonctionnaire je peux vous dire qu'ils
vont effectivement faire des mesures
drastiques encore mais par contre les
quelques mesures
j'allais dire qui permettait d'alléger
l'impôt je n'y crois pas je ne crois pas
qu'elles vont venir donc ils ont tout
simplement parce que ils ont toujours
cette règle imbécile excusez moi le
terme des 3 % avec ça a été décidée à
jour griffonné dans les années 80 sera
plus de 3 ni deux et demi ces trois qui
nous qui nous conduit à faire des
politiques inverse à la gérer l'intérêt
de notre pays